hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show where in this video i'm going to
talk about a recent study that came out
of davidson claire's lab
whereby they developed two different
mouse frailty clocks
one which can predict a mouse's
biological age
and a second clock that can predict when
it will die this not only sets the
stones for further developing a clock
that can work in humans
but also provides a useful tool that can
be applied by
other scientists trying to understand
different interventions
of aging and health span in mice so i'll
begin by addressing what actually is
aging
and the current methods for determining
biological age
and then we'll discuss the highlights
from this recent nature paper
and then finally i'll give some thoughts
and opinions so firstly then
what is aging well one way to define
aging is the progressive deterioration
of an organism over time
and so it's thought that aging is a
dynamic non-linear process
and what that means is basically each of
us age at different rates
in different ways but the problem of
this is that it makes studying aging
really challenging
and so there are two ways that you can
define age chronological age
and biological age so chronological age
refers to the amount of time that has
passed since you were born
whilst biological age is a
time-dependent component of an
organism's overall health
and regarding studies of aging
biological age is being increasingly
used because it aims to more accurately
reflect
aging in an individual than the
conventional chronological age
mobile's chronological age can be easily
determined if you know
when an individual was born there are
various different ways and approaches
that are being developed to try and
determine biological age
i recently highlighted these different
biological aging clocks in a video
that include different clocks such as an
epigenetic clock based on dna
methylation
a proteomic agent clock and clock space
and telomere length and gene expression
all of these different clocks are united
by the fact that they aim to try and
find a way to quantify and define aging
and to be able to evaluate the efficacy
of different aging interventions
however some of the approaches that i've
just mentioned such as dna methylation
clocks
have the caveats of being currently
quite expensive
time consuming and requiring the
extraction of blood or tissue
from an individual and for these reasons
some labs may not have access
to be able to perform some of these
clocks
to be able to understand biological age
in different aging
interventions so one goal would be to
find
an approach that can be more
non-invasive
cheaper and can be employed by a greater
number of people
i'd say that's what they sought to
explore in this recent paper as i
mentioned from davidson clare's lab
and this is from the article age and
life expectancy clocks
based on machine learning analysis of
mouse frailty
and so given by the title they are using
mouse frailty measures
in combination with machine learning
approaches to come up with two different
clocks
one that can determine a mouse's
biological age and a second clock
that can predict how long the mice has
left to live
so to develop both of these clocks the
team needed data
of mice both to originally develop and
then subsequently to test the efficacy
of these clocks
so to get the data they tracked frailty
in a cohort of
aging mice from 21 months of age until
their natural deaths
and so this was in male mice and by
frailty what i mean is they took
data that recorded the frailty index and
they did this
approximately every six weeks in their
population of aging male mice
until the end of their lives so for my
attentive viewers
you may recall that i mentioned the
frailty index when i mentioned
alpha-ketoglutarate in a previous video
but to recap the frailty index
is an assessment that includes and
quantifies
the accumulation of up to 70 different
health-related deficits
including laboratory test results
symptoms diseases
and standard measures such as activities
of daily living
and so it may include factors such as
hearing loss and gait disorders
and so once these different health
related deficits are assessed
you end up with a number between 0 and 1
with the higher the number indicating a
greater degree of frailty
so as we saw with the
alpha-ketoglutarate study
frailty index can be used as an
indicator of how effective different
interventions
are in terms of improving health span
however the authors of this paper wanted
to take
it a bit further and explore how frailty
index could actually be used to model
biological age or predict life
expectancy
so i said at the beginning aging is
dynamic and non-linear
and this is most evident in this figure
here where you can see
the different frailty index measures of
each of the different mice that they
assess in the study
and so we can see firstly that there is
a general
increase of the frailty index which is
expected
however you can see that there's also
much variability within the population
so the frailty index takes into account
each of the different
health-related deficits equally however
the authors suspected that a potentially
more predictive model of biological age
could be achieved
if the different metrics were
differentially weighted within the model
and so by doing this it can take into
account how
individual frailty index items vary in
their correlation with age
and that's most evidence in the second
figure here where you can see that
tail stiffening breathing rate and gait
disorders
hearing loss kyphosis and tremor have
pretty strong correlations
with chronological age conversely some
of the items had no correlation
this included fission loss loss of
whiskers and
cornual capacity just to name a couple
and so the authors took this information
and tried a variety of different
mathematical models to see what would
work best
and eventually they decided that the
random forest models
was most effective and they terms the
outcome clock of their model
fright age for frailty inferred
geriatric health timeline
so the key token is that fright age is
superior to frailty index
at being able to predict chronological
age however fright age wasn't so good
at being able to predict mortality so
to develop a clock that can predict
lifespan the authors
decided to look at the correlation
between each of these
individual frailty index items and
survival and their essential outcome
was the afraid clock standing for
analysis of frailty and death
and so clearly the lab are continuing
the trend of naming these different
clocks such because aging and death are
frightening to many people
and so it goes along with grim age clock
that
is used to look at dna methylation
patterns in humans
and is named after the grim reaper as
the clock
allows one to predict lifespan and
health span and so the nice thing about
the afraid clock is as it has the
potential
to compare lifespan effects of different
interventions
before the death of the different mice
so do these clocks
actually work and will they be effective
so to test their clocks they first use
previously published data
that had treated mice with enalapril
which improved health span but not
lifespan
and they found that their their model
validated their results
as you can see here that an alloprol
in the fright age showed a decrease but
the afraid score was
the same and showed no significant
differences indicative
of being no extension of lifespan
conversely when they placed mice on
methionine restriction
which has been previously shown to
extend both healthspan and lifespan of
male mice
and so by calculating the fright age
they found that the
methionine restricted mice had an age
0.7 months younger than the control fed
mice
and by using their afraid clock they
could predict
that the methionine restricted mice
would live 1.3 months longer
than controls and so they concluded that
their fright age and afraid clock models
are responsive to health span and
lifespan extending interventions
and so the real advantage of using these
different clocks
and using the frailty index measurements
is that
frailty index is really quick and pretty
much free to assess
and doesn't really require any
specialized equipment or training
and it also doesn't have any impacts to
the animals and so the authors
definitely encourage
longevity studies to try and incorporate
periodic frailty assessments
and then to use their clocks to have a
better measurement
of the chronological age and to be able
to predict how long the mice has until
it dies
and so the clocks don't make other
measurements of biological age redundant
it instead provides a potential tool
that will enable
a more accurate comparison between
different intervention studies
so we can have a better understanding of
what these different interventions are
impacting
on health span and lifespan and to
better understand the aging process
itself
now there are some limitations currently
firstly that they
developed these models using
measurements on male mice
and so it'll be very important to also
do a similar analysis on female mice
because there definitely are sex
dependent differences
in aging and longevity moreover there
are limitations
in using these complex mathematical
models including a lack of
interpretability of the waiting and
interactions of the variables
nonetheless the models can be further
improved by including a larger number of
mice to begin with
and also including both more mice
especially at the old ages
but also assessing felty from ages
younger than 21 months of age which is
when they started the study on the mice
and so due to the fact that a lot of
data is needed to develop
such models it may take a while to be
able to apply the same
approaches to develop a clock for human
frailty index data
but in theory the afraid clock could be
easily adapted
to predict mortality from human frailty
index data
but this research highlighted in this
paper is definitely a good step forward
to achieving this goal
so i hope this video has given you some
insight into this recent publication
and i hope you've learned something and
as always thanks for listening